[Music]
hello welcome everybody to Udacity
Robotics QA I'm Mike Salem and I'm here
with CEO and co-founder of 3d robotics
Chris Anderson Chris how are you good
good beer good
so can come a little bit about 3d
robotics how you guys got started yeah
so this may disqualify me entirely but
we actually go by 3d are now ok and you
may ask why did we drop the word
robotics and the answer is because they
work now I said we we have actually been
at this for about 10 years and it
started I was the editor of Wired and I
have I have a lot of kids was just
trying to get them interested in
something robotics and you know failed
with Lego Mindstorms and ended up trying
to you know convince them the flying
robots were a thing they were
unconvinced but I was and started a
community called DIY drones and then
that created big robotics communities to
one of the biggest and big open-source
software stack and then we turned that
into a company 3d robotics then which
like made the hardware so that people
could use this software stack and then
over time we just the drone we got a
Morken and the drones me here's one and
drones were kind of became a solved
problem and the next question is well
what are they good for you know how do
we use the drone data for something
useful in the world and and around last
year the FAA allowed commercial use
without pilot's license and and that was
our opportunity to shift entirely to to
the software data side and we use drones
in construction so we're we Autodesk is
one of our investors and so we use these
things to scan construction sites and
integrate with CAD and talk more about
it but yeah we so at this point our
customers are don't want to buy a robot
they want to buy a drone scan and it's
essentially a button that they push and
it just works or soar pad I pad app they
swipe and so you know robot and and
drone kind of is bright and shiny and
gets you in the door in the early days
but when you actually work you don't
want to use the word robot intimidating
right I think there's a similar
connotation around drone as well yeah
right so I started my career off 2008
doing ground control stations for UAVs
unmanned aerial vehicles right so one of
the things we were always specifically
told was do not use the word
drone okay right I had lots of fights
with people about that initially so
initially when we use the word drone
it's just that I used to be in the media
business and you know in this guide
Marshall McLuhan whether it's like
theory of medium there's this phrase
like hot words hot words may have
positive negative connotations for their
attention-getting and drone is a hot
word initially you know when you were in
the military I was you know an amateur
just sticking it together just just for
clarification of government government
contract militaries are nominal folks
out there government country but you're
using you know kind of aerospace quality
stuff and drones were then associated
with weapons and you know and the
military and everyone said don't use the
word drone because you're only going to
inhibit the commercial recreational
consumer use of this and I'm like but
it's a hot word so I called the site DIY
drones and everyone like you know you
know moaned about it but it kept coming
and now when people tell us not to use
the word drone is because they think it
sounds like a toy and so we have
literally gone from the CIA to Costco in
less than 10 years so talk about a
little bit about when you first started
with this because I remember when I
started with it you know Ross wasn't a
very publicly widely available thing you
know you have different ways of doing
your communication back sure you have
different standards yeah what were some
of the biggest hurdles that you kind of
saw when you first started this effect
well if we'd known about all the hurdles
wouldn't have done it but um so with the
way I got started was I so I have these
dogs five kids and I'm like okay we're
going to do robot so I've got this Lego
Mindstorms robotics kit and then it's
like if that didn't work we had this
radio-controlled airplane and we're
going to do that and so I learned this
terrible lesson about probably about my
kids but maybe a general lesson about
kids which is that robots are kind of
boring real robots that you actually
have to program and so they spent all
morning program the Lego Mindstorms
robotics and I kind of moved slowly
towards the wall and then bounces back
and they're like come on you know I've
seen transformers where the frickin
lasers so Hollywood has ruined robotics
for kids because how do you compete with
CG and like okay cool we'll just go to
the park we'll fly the plane and of
course I flew it right into a tree and
then like that sucked so I mean like how
could that have gone better what would
have been a bit cooler robot and a
better flying plane I thought well what
the robot flew the plane I literally
googled
flying robot
and if you google flying robot it's a
drone it turns out that's what a drone
is it's a flying robot it's like awesome
ground wait what's a drone it's a Google
drone it turns out like it's an airplane
with an autopilot I'm like oh yeah of
course Auto pie wait
what's an autopilot Google autopilot
it's like something about sensors and
computers and it's like okay sensors
computers that sounds like Lego
Mindstorms comes with like compass and
you know accelerometer and gyros and
it's got a computer that's like yeah how
do you put the sensors of computers
together and you Google and it's like
math sounds like okay it's probably tied
us up here those in fairness you also
have a technical background i I did but
the kids you know once we saw common
filter I think the kids were like let's
just do it um so we we did it and it
kind of almost worked and and then it
kids lost interest and I was like I
started this community to sort of say
what the heck is going on if a guy and
his kids can build a kind of a GPS
guided autonomous drone on the dining
room table which by the way on according
to export control regulations we did
weaponize Lego at that at that very
moment by putting on the Internet
so if a guy and his kids can like make
an autonomous drone out of toy parts
what is going on here something of this
world has changed so I started this
community do you about DIY drones to
find out and and everyone was sort of
perceiving the same thing 2007 was the
year that you know that is like some
people had a Wii controller for the you
know the video game rack what's in here
and those guys like accelerometer and
they turn into Fitbit and other people
were you know we're playing around with
3d printers and the maker movement was
just starting and basically the answer
is the iPhone that's the year the iPhone
came out and those sensors became
available so you know it's like okay you
can buy MEMS sensors and good cameras
and GPS and wireless etc you know how do
you put it together and you know none of
us are really expert on the
interdisciplinary skills need for
robotics so we just just started doing
in the first thing we did is we we went
with the development the open source
hardware platform of the day which is
Arduino so we like okay Arduino can talk
to sensors and we know how to program
our an Arduino so let's just make it our
julinho powered drone we called it our g
pilot and it was like a little board
that cost $24 and i went to the big
industry
conference this is a vsi which is okay
just a trade association it was like all
military yeah there's like and they and
some guy invited me in to be the keynote
for reasons that he probably regretted
and it's like general one general -
general three these guys have like you
know oh yeah totally
yeah really other than let's play
actually generals talking about the
future of aviation and then this dude
comes up with this like board that cost
$24 and say open-source you know drones
are the future of aviation and you can
buy an autopilot for twenty four bucks
and sick in the radio control plane do
what these guys are doing and they just
you know I mean they couldn't decide
whether I was crazy or dangerous or both
but the reality is we couldn't really do
what we said at the time because you
know as we we were able to get the
airplanes working that was fine but when
we moved to the copters to the quad
copters nothing worked and we realized
that the thing about airplanes that kind
of want to fly and copters really don't
want to fly and you know our code was
just super lame like it was crashing it
was actually rebooting in the in the air
because of race conditions or whatever
and we didn't know because when an
airplane autopilot reboots
it just keeps flying and when a copter
autopilot reboots it tumbles to the
ground so we had basically by starting
with airplanes we kind of got around we
got away with murder and were able to
kind of kind of get something that
looked like it worked and kind of
vaguely navigated with GPS and then by
the time we turned to copters about two
or three years later and everything
broke we at least had enough confidence
to think that maybe you know we can fix
this to kind of come back to route you
know to first principles and understand
things like common filters and you know
in real-time operating systems and
testing and all that kind of stuff so it
was it was hard and there was some
there's some dark days and the copter
when this when we didn't have proper
simulators and didn't have to talk
proper test environments remember it's
open source which means that people
would take the boards and then stick
them in random vehicles and like
soldered badly and connect things badly
and threw things upside down and
backwards and and so the number of
variables that could go wrong was
essentially unbounded and we didn't have
a kind of a framework to be even I mean
people say you suck because my drone
crashed and we're like they might be
right we might suck
but but we don't know and until we had
the ability to data log the whole thing
and and auto auto tune them and all this
kind of stuff when there was moments
where we were like weren't sure whether
they soft or we sucked and it turned out
that it's mostly them then being the
users right and we did suck but we
didn't suck as badly as they thought and
we eventually stopped sucking now when
you talk about flying these you're
talking about going from basically a
small small scale plane into copter
right was there any communication that
you had with it once you once you launch
it into the air yeah um so um we have a
ground station sure so the idea was
drones in our mind are autonomous
now the word autonomy is obviously here
here one must not use the word autonomy
loosely but in our mind it was basically
GPS guided so automatic takeoff
automatic mission automatic landing you
know no touchy
we do have ground stations that the
ground stations were largely to monitor
just to monitor the data as it came in
you can dynamically change the mission
so when your ground stations probably
and you're in your contractor days you
would do things like you would click on
something and like loiter here or go
there or look at that right those are
those typical or the typical things you
would have to kill me if you didn't tell
me that anyway those kind of
higher-level
mission commands were what we were doing
we just had a radio link it was an issue
it was like things like XPS later on we
built our own radios then we as years
went on video became more of a thing and
digital video became more thing today a
ground station was largely a lens its
buys it largely your visualization you
know your your you know your your
viewfinder if you will on what is
largely a flying camera and in our case
you know we do have ground stations but
it's really just for FAA compliance
which is the FAA wants a pilot in
command which is funny because there is
no pilot and they're not in command
right but they're there and if a if
there was a reason like some emergency
services lock coupler would come in here
they can pull up their tablet and press
a button say come home and that's what's
boiled down to yes I know one of the big
things that we used to work with is
actually line of sight communication so
that's always a big thing when you have
a ground control station and you have a
vehicle flying in the air you want to
make sure that you have communication
with that vehicle at all kinds yeah
which is defined by the F
is visual line of sight which is I mean
you know we love the FAA they're
actually being really helpful right now
but it is crazy because visual line of
sight is never defined visualize sight
could be that tiny black dot of my own
the distance you can see it but do you
know the orientation you really see how
far this can you see what's around it
whereas but it begin to the FAA to find
is unassisted visual line of sight and
you and I both know these things are
bristling with cameras if you would let
me go assist it in other words look at
how look at what the drone can see I do
a much better job of taking over control
but it's not allowed yeah definitely so
so going from the small scaled planes to
basically copters right one of the
interesting things that you're
mentioning here actually is that a lot
of your code broke the reboots right
things would just kind of tumble out of
the skies but now you see these these
types of drones pretty much everywhere
right this is like the preferred method
it seems like for consumer drones why do
you think that is the case you think
it's because they're able to loiter and
stabilize better or the movement is more
controlled the reason that copters have
one any a fixed-wing which I love is
pretty much gone at this point is
because they speak about landing so the
you know you want drones to be able to
kind of fit into any environment so you
know your backyard in the street a
construction site whatever which means
they essentially have to be vertical
takeoff and landing the problem with
fixed-wing is physics which is that they
only fly when they're moving forward
which means that you know you need some
areas of land and you know we thought
about we spent so many years trying to
kind of perfect vertical takeoff and
landing and maybe it'll happen but but
basically you know they fixed-wing needs
to need to sort of be moving forward you
can have it spiral down but it still
needs to be moving forward typically
need to be moving into the wind and so
it needs like you know at least 10
meters and then you've got trees and so
you can't you can't just you know can't
go it was a zinc and land it kind of has
to come down and land and these things
are always getting caught in trees and
you know there's like parachutes that's
just another thing to get caught in
trees so now it's like vertical takeoff
and landing which is which is great
except for the problem with airplanes
they have wings which means that
essentially catching the wind and sails
and so vertical takeoff and landing
works great until twin D and then it's
just
back in the tree yeah definitely I can't
tell you how many vehicles I've heard
from the small UAVs like you know these
planes that have crashed burned on the
way down and you're talking anywhere
from thirty thousand dollars to a couple
million dollars yeah it's not exactly
the best way to go no it's not so
basically the recent copters work there
isn't copper sticking over is that they
are the easiest thing to do they
literally are you push a button and they
do it you don't have to think about when
you don't think about throwing you don't
have to think about landing you know
they they turn a drone into you know
something it can be autonomous in any
situation with no skills so I know
you've pivoted your company slightly
rights is going from manufacturing to
actually a great realization right can
you tell me a little bit about some of
the utilization you have right now for
for your drones yeah so the plan was
always to do this he says he says only
slightly defensively so you know the
plan was always there's to be three
phases of the industry phase one was the
technology let's just get the robots to
fly and this is the auto pilots and the
sensors and the comm stack and the
control you know then the and the the
ground control systems and all that and
and that took us that took us like five
years or even longer not as a company
the company is only four years old but
as a community that was hard okay then
in the next phase was okay now that they
work let's make them easy to use and
that means turn them into a consumer
electronics product which you know which
which you could just open the box under
the Christmas tree and press go and and
that in turns out the skills necessary
to get robots to fly bear almost no
resemblance to the skills necessary to
make a computer electronics product
those are all about manufacturing supply
chain distribution retail customer
support all that kind of stuff and then
and then the third phase was always
going to be okay
there's tech then there's toy then tool
for alliterative sake yeah sure right
and tool is going to be like let's put
them to work let's let's put sensors in
the sky because really the what you know
why are we doing this and the answer is
to measure the planet you got satellites
up there you got Internet of Things down
here and this is like the Internet of
flying things it was going to be you
know sensors in the sky so we could
measure the planet so we can manage it
and that was always the plan and we
always we always knew that we were going
to be there
question is we weren't going to sure we
weren't sure what part of the planet we
were going to measure is it agriculture
is it going to be scientific sensing and
we actually thought it was going to be
agriculture initially because it makes
so much sense right it's a huge industry
very hard to measure
you know chemicals and water there's a
lot of inefficiencies turns out
agriculture is really fragmented a lot
of the the inefficiency in efficiencies
in agriculture are insulated from the
farmer because the things like insurance
and crop subsidies and and so you know
we were kind of fiddling around a little
bit with like inspection and cell tower
get them cell phone towers and things
like that and then a friend of mine in
Berkeley named Carl bass is it was CEO
of Autodesk II and I you know played
play tennis every every weekend and you
know and there they were Autodesk
essentially owns the construction
industry although all the the CAD
software that's used to design design
buildings it is is Autodesk and they
were like you know I said here's the
thing with them with you know with
software and construction is that
everything's digital in the design but
then the moment you dig a spade of Earth
its analog and you know you've lost the
ability to measure now it's paper and
you know in India the lifecycle is ended
so we need to redo ties the construction
site so that you can continue to manage
it with the same tools used to design it
it's called Building Information
modelling and they were like well okay
makes perfect sense it's called reality
capture so how we can do reality capture
and so they were thinking well lidar and
light are on the inside works great but
it's kind of hard to scan a whole site
lidar they were like maybe
photogrammetry you know click like click
on the ground but you know getting it's
the wrong perspective and so became
clear as we talked that we were the
capture that drones with capture in
reality capture the way that
construction industry is the second
biggest in the world the average
commercial product project is 80 percent
cost of a run so it's an eight trillion
dollar industry that really should be
like a five trillion dollar industry
except for that you know that 3 3
billion 3 trillion dollars worth of
inefficiency and and they don't not
insulated like like when a project runs
over cost somebody pays you most these
projects end up in a lawsuit because of
mistakes stumps something happened
between as designed and as built so it
was the parallel paths of Autodesk and
and drones that made that allowed us to
serve that construction was the right
industry for us to measure and that was
the right industry for us to manage and
that this big macro trend in
construction to go digital was the macro
trend that these would be part of it's
great I know you talked a little bit
about this transition that you went from
you know tech the toy to tool what's it
like kind of ramping up a manufacturing
process and kind of putting these things
at a large scale
so this is something I know a lot of
folks out there yeah I'm really
interested in like there's like all I'm
going to build a company and then from
this company we're gonna sell millions
of units but there's this huge piece of
the puzzle that really kind of goes
until the very last step and then it
circles back and you're like wow I
didn't realize how much work this was
going to be this is like the curse of
Kickstarter like I think I think I
decided like the very worst amount of
money you can raise on Kickstarter as a
million dollars somewhere between a
million and ten million dollars because
if you raise like fifty thousand bucks
you know how to make three thousand
boards right so say it's your same sort
of like hacker mentality you raise a 100
million dollars you can hire
professionals do this you may raise like
a million dollars and now you're they've
got raised you created real expectations
real volumes you have to switch from
you're kind of you know DIY practices to
like contract manufacturing with supply
chain know that's kinda stuff you've got
none of the skills so the problem
actually kind of interesting of those
three those three levels the skills that
that cannot allow you to win in tech are
not the schools that allow you to win
skills that will allow you to win in toy
which are also not the skills that allow
you to win in tool and and I would say
we won in tech at 3dr we're going to win
in tool and we got our asses kicked in
toy because we were up against a company
called DJI which is based in Shenzhen
and they basically know that company
happened but you know all the people
they hired have been making iPhones for
the last ten years and taking notes the
whole time
and the notion of supply chain
management and you know efficient
distribution and you know all those
skills that are kind of just in the
water in Shenzhen are hard to learn you
think oh I'll just go contract man
fracturing it's when you're up against a
company as good as gg I'm moving as
quickly as that it's not fast enough and
it's you know so we did really good we
yeah we hired a great team we had great
contract manufacturers we were PCH etc
and and we came out with a product that
was priced at about fifteen hundred
dollars this is the the early consumer
version of this price about fifteen
hundred dollars which was at the low end
of the you know the sophisticated ones
at the time and had a bill of materials
about half that nine months later the
going price the sales price you know in
michelle's of Walmart was $4.99 Wow
so like it's seventy percent cost
declines in nine months because you know
we were up against now this is what
happens in anyway that my only if
there's anybody takes any advice from
this it's like all you guys who were
doing you know heart robotics robotics
hardware and you're saying yeah I
totally get it China is really good I
know the commodification is coming but
we have three to five years you've got
three to five months it's happening much
much faster we were one of the first
companies to kind of go up against a
true 21st century you know a you know
Chinese production unicorn who did
everything right right it wasn't just
the innovation yes they really innovate
it wasn't you know n in software and in
hardware and they went global upfront
and they had handled distribution and
marketing and design up front and and
there are countless other Chinese
companies that are getting ready to do
that now so find one you know if you're
if you're if you want to do a hardware
product find a Chinese company that's
this that's thinking about this a
partner early because they're coming
great here's some great advice so can we
talk a little bit about this John here
in particular so this is one of the
drones that we use for your construction
site yeah yeah so this is basically this
is a site scan unit and it comes in a
box and basically it's a it you know
what - it's a standard kind of consumer
grade drone except for a couple things
first of all it's got a really fancy
camera on here this is a Sony art MC
camera which is a custom one they made
for us but just I think I can't remember
what's called as a consumer one but
basically it's a it's a it's a it's all
about with cameras is all about the
glass I mean it's a big sensor but it's
really about the glass and this will at
200 feet which is kind of a safe
altitude this will do less than
two centimetres per pixel Wow which is
good I'm good enough for Castro
definitely it's um it's it's not doing
video doing still so it's on it's on a
pointer rather than a kind of a highly
it's a stabilized gimbal but it's not
when you use for video but most
importantly we control it with a drone
so you know when we when we when we in
the app you say I want a 3d scan of this
or a 2d scan of this or an inspection
whatever the algorithm that does all the
the merging of the images in the cloud
it knows what it wants so it's like you
know
so the algorithm might say well you know
I'm gonna want 50% overlap and insight
lap I want you know the algorithms can
these these do photogrammetry which is
basically extract position from the
geometries of the you know of the
features they actually want
translationally what features our
facility yeah so so em the way this does
is takes photos and they overlap and so
like you know one that one the feature
could be your shoe sure right if I see
your food your shoe from this photo and
in this photo and that photo if I just
you know trace lines you know through
those there's a foreground in the
background I could say the same feature
seen from different perspectives allow
me to figure out where my camera is so
they're typically unique points of
interest exactly identifiable points of
interest and typically the software will
find those on their own these unique
colors or shapes and things like that
and so this is called photogrammetry or
reconstruction and it you know this
finds position from from from from line
tracing through through objects so the
algorithm wants the certain things that
work better so a certain amount of
motion a certain amount that they like
translation better than rotation and and
there's certain you know settings
fergus's so motion blur is really bad
certain lighting you know contrast is
good etc so all so the algorithm
basically tells the camera via the drone
what it wants and then we construct a
mission which to it to a human eye might
look really weird you know sometimes we
hatched sometimes we we lawnmower
sometimes we circle sometimes we do all
of the above and we point for your iPad
on for the flight path transaction and
we point the camera throughout
and all of this is because we're talking
to the algorithm and know in real some
times in real time sometimes ahead of
time what the algorithm is going to want
from this particular image and then we
control the camera settings that the
shutter speed and the aperture settings
of all this accordingly so that's why
that's what you want kind of a smart
system because because you know
ultimately it's going to the cloud and
it's about the data the data quality
that's going to produce the mesh you
want
yeah and that stitching process is
actually very you know computationally
expensive right it is yeah which is why
we do it in the club yeah definitely
it's still 2 hours how long are I don't
know if you could say this or not but
how larger your images typically in
terms of science 20 megapixels so yeah
it's you got some really fine grain
granularity yeah our stitching back
together and when you're laying these
mosaics exactly so we typically send it
somewhere between two and three hundred
photos to the cloud of that resolution
and you end up with what's either called
North erecta fied in 2d image which is
basically is as if the kemon was always
looking straight up and down and the
reason you care about that is we look
straight up and down all the 90-degree
angles are 90 degrees no distortion
right you can also get a mesh which is
basically a 3d model where it's all
polygons or you can get a point cloud
and the interesting thing about point
clouds is that's the same data that a
laser scanner would give you and so then
you can combine your laser data on the
inside and from the ground with your
photogrammetry data and it all sort of
is on the same orientation coordinate
plane do you want to take them just a
little bit further of a dive into the
point cloud mapping and kind of
explaining that method a little bit it's
one of the methods actually our students
are gonna learn in a program yeah so I'm
I'm sorry just interjected they didn't
do with an RGB D type of image though
too but just from a pure camera
perspective okay okay well so it's so
the easiest way to think about a point
clouds with a laser scanner which is to
say that you know that a laser is is
pulsing at a certain rate and traveling
at a certain rate and so basically each
one of those pulse angles which is it
bounces off something right and that's
something it bounces off as a point and
ends in 3d space and you can decide to
connect the points with polygons and you
can get shapes now they what a camera
does
essentially the same thing but it does
it all in software so now you have a
feature which is seen from two or two
orientations and where the where the
Rays intersect is the point and the
interesting thing about a camera is that
you also have a texture map so although
you can take the points and build a
polygon a mesh around it now you have
the textures from the actual photos
themselves or you can now project onto
the mesh and now you have a beautiful 3d
model that looks that looks
photorealistic perfect great that was a
great explanation thank you for that so
talking a little about the construction
site a little bit more so right now
you're doing this to kind of do
reconstruction of 3d scenes so anything
else that you would like to see actually
we I thought because you know because
you know in the demos we always show
like 3d model you know scanning 3d model
it's photorealistic and the construction
guys are like couldn't care less we are
we live in a 2d world right so you know
if you go to a construction site each
paper they print out these layers it's
all it's all 2d and we're like oh ok so
what you really want as north of the
orthographic you know projection and so
what we what we end up doing mostly is
um maybe there's a three phases of the
site there's the there's where it's a
barren site and it's about dirt in
topologies and and and and you want to
characterize the site you want to know
you know exactly you know its its its
elevation and we do something called a
digital elevation map that comes out of
this you want to get as a whole you
wanna know how big the hole is that
there's a hill that you need to take
down you wanna know how big is you know
like you moving dirt in or you move dirt
out and you want to be able to see q2 to
place it in that you know exactly in the
right coordinate system
by the way a little aside this is one of
the things I learned so you would
probably think that the coordinate
system of the world is latitude
longitude not the construction world the
construction world has local coordinate
systems and the way to think about this
is when we are in America and you know
America was uncharted territory and
people came out and these were these
were surveyors and they they wanted to
sort of like draw lines for states and
cities and property lines and things
like that and they would like sight the
Stars and they whatever they would a
surveyor would that stick out a stone
post and that's
post a zero zero in that coordinate
system okay and then the next guy would
come along with the telescope and they
would site off the stone post and that
would be you know
16:41 they'd be like 1632 on that
coordinate system until you get about
five telescope lengths away all
line-of-sight and that point you're like
yeah our air bars are starting to build
up a little bit it's time to bring put
down another stone post and that's
another coordinate system so we you'd
probably think it we're here a lot luan
long something right but if you ask your
your your landlord about the property
line they'll tell you where you are and
the what what town are we in um view
yeah you're in the Mountain View East
you know to coordinate system and and it
really matters because when you go to
the county office and say this is where
I want to do they're going to pull up
the records of like who who's your
proper where the property line is and
they're all in these local coordinate
systems so that's one of the things that
you know you we got away with murder and
GPS in the real world you have to speak
their language wow that's that's a
really interesting thing so I know for
the flights that and flight patterns
that we used to do is all GPS based so
yeah jumping into that coordinate system
must be must be a little bit of a
challenge well the I mean the hard the
hard thing is is that you know it we
were taking pretty pictures in like a
pretty picture and they're like yeah
that does me no good you know here's
here's here's my world my world is is
you know paper CAD files with layers
that have coordinate systems and if your
data isn't doesn't speak my language is
not meaningful to me so we had to first
geo-reference it onto their coordinate
system then we had to what's called
rubber sheet it which means we have to
dimensionalize it in both directions so
that everything lines up and we have to
do that with these things called ground
control points and they basically taken
RTK gps which is super high precision
GPS and they put like these lines give
these little dots here and you go around
and you stick a couple like known points
on the site that are really accurate
then you stick like a an orange post on
it or like a big like a pie plate or
something like that
and what our software does is it spots
the ground control points and then
dimension Eliza's the data - to it to
match with that Wow it's really cool so
really advanced way of the gun world is
messy so a couple more questions I have
for you around this topic is um if I
wanted to come and work at a company
like 3dr what kind of skills what I need
well
um in the early days our skills were so
the software that we were building was
all open-source and today we've moved it
all of that into into the Linux
Foundation and it's called drone code
and I'm the chairman I started it and
chairman of that and so all that early
work is now a very sophisticated full
stack that's it's all BSD licensed and
it's everything from you know the
low-level sensor through the auto pilot
to the comm stack the ground stations
and even the cloud and regulatory
compliance and all that so that's so if
you want to do kind of like you know
robot software that's that's now in the
community you're very welcome to
contribute but that's not the company
then the next phase was it was the the
board's the electronics and that was a
lot of what started with simple stuff
like Arduino again we got away with
murder in those early days you know two
layer boards 16 megahertz you know I
mean it was you know you can lay it out
and do it yourself now a basically look
like smartphones and so you typically
the the autopilots will be like a
Qualcomm or an Intel one and they you
know you know BGA you know chips it's
it's um it's pretty hard stuff so so
electronics is kind of like you kind of
use smartphone stuff as best you can or
raspberry pies or things like that then
you got into the consumer electronics
side and that was all mechanical you
know how do you come up with the
composites and the design that minimizes
weight maximizes flight time noise is
one of the problems with drones and so
really it's a slightly there's a lot of
solved problems with drones today but
one of the unsolved problems is that
there's still a little bit noisy
definitely and annoying and the pitch is
like right on that kind of like rating
the other thing and that's a combination
of speed the speed it turns they design
the propeller the the turbulent
interaction between the propeller and
the body and then resonant frequencies
and nodes within the body and you know
to kind of to run this so we run this
through a lot of simulators we run them
through mechanical simulators cost
simulators strength simulators but you
also want to run it through a an
acoustic simulator to try to minimize
that so that's so on the consumer
electronic side mechanical still a thing
but on our side now where we are today
when you look at our team we do
front-end web
which is you know the the tools on the
on our web manager that people use this
back-end web which is doing some of the
machine learning and and integration of
drone data and photogrammetry data and
then we have iOS apps or mobile apps
which are not not super hard but you
know from a kind of UI perspective but
need to sort of speak drone language as
well so I would say that you know
basically think of drones as good having
entered their data era and it's less
about the robot and more about the data
which means that machine learning you
know neural network computer vision a
big data analysis built see to possibly
identify features and and and you know
and project them those are the skills we
need now data engineering I would
imagine to for managing pipelines of
allows data we're lucky in that we work
closely with Autodesk and they and they
handle all of that that's nice but but
yeah that's a big problem for a lot a
lot of folks out there yeah it is and
one of the things that we said we're
with this is example cloud robotics and
I don't know if you talked about yes
we've actually done survey papers in our
research group in our slack community on
cloud robotics so the beauty of cloud
robotics is that you have you have you
have the robot and the other cloud and
you can kind of use them both as
appropriate which is to say you know
that maybe you know you push the
computational function upstream into the
cloud and and to allow the robot to be
smarter I theoretically we do that in
practice the you know in there in the
real world our communication links are
pretty
I think non-deterministic is Jace's way
to say it there well is sometimes
they're good sometimes are bad and
sometimes they don't exist at all and so
you know an interesting question is like
I described a scenario by which we
dynamically adjust the mission so in
your world back in your near old days um
you probably defined a mission and then
the mission determined the data but I in
a perfect world you define need to find
the date you'd say list that was the
data I want and it would just figure out
what the mission is to get that data
right so so the data would determine the
mission and you know the drone would
just go to wherever the data was needed
and would figure it out that loop
closure that's our dynamic
planning which uses the sort of the
algorithms
you know steering the drone if you will
that's a perfect example of cloud
robotics and we haven't figured out
exactly how to reliably do that with the
comms links we have so that's a that's a
systems architecture problem we haven't
solved how nice no there's some things
in the field that can always be improved
upon right dude so one last question for
you on this topic is 3d are hiring we
are we're hiring back-end and engineers
back and back and web developers I have
to say that in fair awarding we do use
Scala ok I in some of our back-end
systems not all of them I know that's
their reasons for us sure we're not
wedded to it but if you happen to know
Scala that that's great and we're hiring
iOS developers as well perfect so let's
go ahead and take some questions from
the audience if you don't mind can we
talk about cars at some point -
absolutely so you want to go talk about
it now we can get all clearly for a take
question absolutely so the story I just
told you was ten years ten years ago DIY
drones you know community turns into a
company company turns into a business we
don't do we don't do drugs anymore
because we get them right we're starting
it all over again we're doing with cars
so DIY robo cars and so what we have
here is so cars are interestingly harder
than drones they're harder than drones
for a couple reasons today they fly in
very they're the operating crowded
environments they don't always have GPS
so it's about computer vision and lidar
and things so so we got again we get
away with murder because we have GPS and
because we can kind of you know we know
we can fly like in a big oh yeah there's
not a whole lot that run into either a
lot a guy exactly these things don't
have that and so when when you know when
I as the nerd not the CEO and I as the
nerd went looking for the next hard
problem it became clear that cars are
right where drones were ten years ago
which is to say that the core
technologies of lidar and computer
vision and open-source software are now
easy enough for a regular person to use
but I don't have one I didn't have a
drone in 2007 you had a drone but I
didn't have a drum because it cost 10
million dollars now I don't have an
autonomous card because because I don't
have one because I don't have a test my
wife won't let me buy a Tesla and she
won't let me act a family SUV so what am
I going to do
I could take the Udacity course in doing
simulation but you know frankly I want
to get my hands dirty sure so we decided
to put the D at words letters DIY in
front of autonomous cars and basically
take the audacity self-driven cars stack
and implemented at less than $250 so
this this ridiculous thing is basically
everything you would find in a Tesoro or
Google car but like not as good but you
can have one of these is that this is we
have instructions on the site is
basically $250 with a stuffy buy on
Amazon and lidar right now it's 2d
skimming a lidar cost less than $200 we
use a raspberry pi's because they should
think um because you can run tensorflow
on them they run computer vision they're
connected to the invade of us clouds and
we race them wheel to wheel in a big
warehouse in Oakland every month the
next one is on June 17th and right now I
run the computer vision team and there's
other guys who run the neural network
team the tensorflow team and right now
the neural network team is a little
ahead which would shall not last but you
know we think of this as being like the
Tesla approach which is kind of a
computer vision approach versus the
Google way mo approach which is like a
neural network approach sure so it's
like Tesla versus Google yeah you know
wheeled a wheel at like 30 miles an hour
this one doesn't go through D but the
others do in a in a crazy Auckland
warehouse and you know may the best code
win definitely and if you're in the
Oakland area if people should come and
check that out
yeah we also have them we have meetups
that do this in Washington DC in New
York and Austin Texas and we're looking
for more so go to DIY robo cars calm and
and see you on the nya the 19th awesome
sounds great let's go ahead and shift a
couple questions from the community I'm
sure a lot of folks eager to talk to you
so we have some some questions here from
Adam hi Chris thanks for taking our
questions I know you made a mid-career
transition from journalist entrepreneur
can you speak about your experience
going from tech journalists to tech CEO
also can you provide any guidance for
those of us who are thinking of going
from employee to entrepreneur mid-career
to consider thanks again totally yeah
good question simple my career looks
super random and it is a little random
but actually I was I was trained as a
computational physicist and you know and
unfortunately physics kind of cratered
because we didn't have couldn't afford
particle accelerators anymore so I had
to go off and do other stuff this
actually is computational physics so you
know sir
physics - drone makes perfect sense the
weird thing is like the whole media
thing in between and it was basically
just I went from one from the from doing
physics to working for the big
scientific journal Science in nature and
then the Economist again doing doing
sort of Science and Technology and then
and then and then wired and then Rand
wired because we're sort of telling the
story of all this and and what seemed
like the most the most exciting story of
the day I a little bit of clarification
I was actually the editor of Wired not a
journalist and so I was running a
company called a magazine but is about
120 people and today I run a company but
about the same size so anchors going
from editor to CEO is is really quite
straightforward sure you know they're
the product was a magazine here the
product is a drone or software but is
the same kind of cycles you know we had
monthly sprints
you know milestones and you know and
pipelines and it that that was actually
quite similar the do to go from writer
you know I was also writing books like
the longtail on free acres etc to go
from writer to entrepreneur is a little
less obvious I would say the only key
key connection there is that
communicating what you're doing clearly
is a good asset in any discipline it's
good for your team it's good it's a way
to get investors and so when you think
about writing as a way to essentially
market an idea you know that's a great
skill for for anybody so that was the
first question the second question was
about Oh from transitioning from
mid-career from employing into into
entrepreneur um this actually my fifth
company but it's the first one I did
full-time so you know the my other
companies I had so many crazy companies
I had a company that did mobile gaming
in 2009 before there was any mobile
which was good idea but it's all about
timing um transitioning to to to running
my own company uh that was actually not
that hard because what we did is we
started the company as a side project
and so by the time we raise venture
capital and I left wired and took over
CEO the company was already five million
dollars of revenues I already had about
70 employees was being run by my
co-founder Geordi munos and it's a
terrific story basically a Mexican
Tijuana teenager I met on the internet
it turned out to be absolutely brilliant
um so we D risked it entirely and so I
would encourage people to not like quit
their job and start a company but rather
get us get a hobby right turn that hobby
into a kind of a pro side project try to
kind of take it as far as you can you
know to de-risk it is there were
something there and the moment there's
something there then dive in with both
feet I mean focus is super important but
you don't have to you know you don't
have to quit your job and start a
company before you know there is a
company there I think that's great
advice and actually a lot of successful
people actually emulate that kind of
pattern
I call this industrializing your hobbies
a have a hobby you know B grow your
hobby as fast as you can
sessions are great and a certain point
somebody's going to say hey that's that
might be a thing that could be a company
and that's a signal so this next
question is from Rp
hi Chris and thanks for taking the time
to do this 3dr was built on the open
source community you helped found your
perspective on open source as well
publicized but what are some of the
pitfalls you have encountered yeah so
this is a tricky one and and emotionally
kind of kind of complicated as well so
I'm a big believer in open source
everything I do everything I have done
in my career and all this stuff is all
open source now a certain point even not
everything can be open source but I but
I believe in it strongly I started the
arch pilot you know project to start you
know several others and and today drone
code is is open source um what I what I
learned as we scaled is that something I
had paid no attention to which is
licenses actually turns out to be really
important and so as the community grew
you know we you know
it was you know we had the structure
that you know the projects properly and
one thing people don't recognize about
open source is that actually traditional
command control you know rules apply to
open source as well you need can
imitators and roles and responsibilities
and meetings and you know you should
hire a new fire you know they're not
paid but need a vision to meet a vision
so you need like a benevolent dictator
and and I and I played that role for for
a while um as as it succeeded and we
ended up putting more than a million
drones in the air on this platform and
it's still going very strong along it we
entered the commercial era in the
commercial era we wanted big companies
so and then in the early days we wanted
developers to adopt them and in hobbyist
to adopt it Network great but when Big
Time it was time for big companies to
adopt them to adopt this this software
suddenly we needed we had to get super
sophisticated about licenses and it
turns out we'd we'd again with my own
total acquiescence and and and an
approval we had adopted the gplv3
which is a copyleft license and
companies will not adopt gplv3 code
because of its spiral nature and it's by
it requires all derivatives to be to be
open sourced and company's a don't like
do that themselves big companies don't
like to do this themselves and be too
very worried about the GPL and affecting
the rest of their code bases and so we
had companies like Intel and Qualcomm
who have rules about this and the GPL
was like a no-go so unfortunately we had
a second project that came out of th the
University in Zurich and that project
called px4 was BSD licensed which is
called a permissive license and a
permissive license allows you to to not
open source it if you if you don't want
to and so we end up having to fork
having basically split the two and and
the MPX and drone code was now based
around the px4 bsd stack and RG pilot is
doing great even better than it did did
when I was running it as a standalone
under the GPL stack but it was a it was
a divorce and it was it was it was angry
and it made me sad because I love those
guys but it was just a learning process
about how licenses matter great so what
do you see as the future for drone code
for drone code yeah so we're announced
we're going to be releasing our next
stack the one point version 1.6 I think
on Monday it's super good is the best
test that we've ever had and it is we
just relaunched the site as well and we
are now it's now it is now production
ready which is to say that
professional-grade autopilots can run on
this it's we're working with the FAA on
regulatory compliance it is tested at
almost I would say I don't know what the
aerospace grade is the right way to put
it but it's test is the best tested
we've ever done so it is you know this
notion of a kind of an Android
equivalent so you know the model was
where Android DGI is iOS right
unfortunately we don't have a Google you
know to to be the sponsor so instead we
have Intel and Qualcomm and a
manufacturer called unique and 3d are
etc and and you know we've we've got to
the point where the first commercial
vehicles using the drone code stack will
be coming out in August of this year so
right now if you want to use it use a
development platform like Intel arrow or
Snapdragon flight but if you want a
commercial vehicle that just runs drone
code you're going to have to wait till 2
August and I won't tell you who's going
to release it sounds good a little bit
but that that's the stay tuned for that
one right exactly you know we're ready
for primetime so the next one is how
problematic do you consider a single
vendor dominance of the drone space to
its future development well you know if
you're going to be dominated by a single
vendor you know hope that they're good
and the good news is that DJI is just
freaking amazing
so right now DJI dominates the hardware
aside and they dominated not because
they cheated they dumped me because they
just are great they innovated they
innovated fast they've brought prices
down
they bought quality up so you know I for
one welcome our heart our DJI overlords
it's a little bit like the it like of
the iPhone in the early days how
problematic was it that Apple dominated
the iPhone for the first five years you
know smartphones not problematic at all
they did a great job at a certain point
I think their will that you know there
will be some some concerns about that
kind of dominance under concern could be
pure you know you know what if they turn
evil you know what if they stop
executing so well
others is you know frankly a
geopolitical which say as drones become
more and more important and as the data
goes into the cloud there's going to be
some people who just you know the US
government for example will not allow
its its agencies to buy DJI drones right
now because of concern the data about
like where the government is flying is
going to go back to - to China I don't
think there's any evidence that that's
that's a concern but you can see in this
in this kind of fraud political
environment sure there's going to be
some some demand for that and then
finally I think this is the most
important one I think there's going to
be demand for an openstack
to go along with a closed stack again
I'm a huge believer of openness or of
open innovation
and I think right now you know goes in
cycles there was the open face when we
were just getting the technology to work
then there was the closed face where we
need it to be you know vertically
integrated and really you know you know
work well that's where we are right now
and now I think there's gonna be in time
for an open face as well and DJI has an
SDK which is good but we have a full
open we're open at every layer with
drone code and it may be the innovation
shifts down to the camera side that's
not open on the DJI side or maybe it
moves up to the cloud side and so you
need what because we're not sure right
now we want to keep our options open
with the openness possible stack perfect
okay thank you for that answer so this
next question is from Sri ik if one does
open source their product what kind of
precautions should be taken and how do
you ensure custom consumer loyalty yeah
so there's two elements the open source
hardware and open source software we did
both in the early days I would say open
source software if you open your
software you know there's a lot there's
a lot you can read about about moms
icing open source it's actually quite a
good andreessen horowitz podcast
it goes a 16z podcast particularly about
monetizing open source software you know
the answer with open source software is
you typically take a service layer that
service layer could be a user interface
it could be management layer it could
just be a in education that packaging
layer and you monetize that so for
example we we use open source software
but we have proprietary user interfaces
like our app and our cloud services are
not open source anything that goes in
the cloud can more easily to make closed
source
so I think that that's really easy the
hardware side is harder
we were seduced by the success of
Arduino to believe that open-source
hardware was the way to go and I think
in in retrospect we were wrong in two
dimensions
first of all hardware has gotten a lot
harder in the Arduino era was you know
anybody could create one of those boards
and do a derivative design today the
boards are running it seems we're
running at gigahertz speed it was eight
layer boards you know you can
open-source aboard but you know regular
people can't do anything with it in fact
you're just enabling the cloners so you
know what we found with open source
hardware and and I think is really good
for consumers is that the Chinese love
it so today you can buy an Arduino for a
dollar sixty each board with free
shipping in China Wow so I was talking
to Massimo Banzi there you know one of
the founders of the Arduino project a
Maker Faire this this weekend and he's
like you know this is Massimo Banzi
like successful project and we're having
the same conversation we've had for 12
years which is how do we build a
business around or do we know they still
haven't figured it out and I haven't
figured out either that for them because
the hardware is commoditized so quickly
and and you know these you know you're
essentially enabling the cloners that's
great for consumers it's great for
innovations great for the world but I
can't figure out how to build a business
around open source hardware which is why
we don't do that anywhere yeah I get it
so this next question is actually from
lunar port pulse this is the last
question so I am a PhD student studying
autonomous drones for indoor or GPS and
radio or even Vision denied conditions
where human operators cannot control
through radio and computer vision hardly
work how does 3d robotics go with this
topic and how do you view this in the
current and future positions of the
drone industry yes a we chose not to go
into that market for a couple reasons
first of all it's not clear there is a
market there I mean you know the what
indoor drones what are they for there
was absent going to be an answer but I
couldn't figure out what it was you know
the initial stuff was like reading
barcodes on in in warehouses and things
like that
crowd surveillance maybe or something
like that airports indoors with drones I
mean we have cameras sure right if
you're inside a building
cameras everywhere you know don't take
the camera there just put cameras
everywhere so you know I think I'm
probably wrong a poverty of imagination
but we could never find a big market for
indoor drones secondly you know if you
do want to create a local Positioning
System there's lots of ways to do that
that dose doesn't involve vision you can
have ultra wideband you can have
ultrasonic you can have you know light
in indoor positioning systems thirdly we
assume that Google was going to solve
the indoor you know the visual slam
problem and with the you know tango and
in there and there the stuff they
announced more recently I think they
probably will
so we basically said and say we're not
sure it's a market it's way early all
the technology solutions right now suck
there's probably some much easier ways
to solve this over time and so we just
decided not not to go into it at all and
and to date there has not yet and a
market for indoor drones there are
demands for GPS denied drones outside
and it's typically the military that
wants those in our world you know we
have GPS it works pretty you know in
construction site office we're in the
open skies almost always works if it
doesn't work we have optical flow and
some and visual odometry which works
well enough we even have dead reckoning
which will work well enough so we never
had a need for GPS denied you know so
for robust long-term GPS denied
solutions and we do have vio visual
odometry there in case we need it
I know that grad students love this
topic there's like three topics of grad
students absolutely love that we've
never found a market for one swarming I
I you know it is swarming like the
number one robotics you know one of my
favorite areas but yeah it there's as
far as I can tell zero demand for true
swarming of that of that sort and so the
first thing we do is you know when one
resumes come in they did swarm enough oh
god okay right so you know onboarding
forget swarming there's no market for it
I'm probably wrong but that's a the
second one is GPS denied cannot find you
know a market for it and and the third
one
is GPS spoofing which is actually kind
of interesting this is regulatory
compliance and airspace they're kind of
seven that one that probably is a market
for and in the military in particular
GPS spoofing is a real is a real thing
you know when you have active
interference but it's not what I know
anything about so and I can neither
front confirming a diagnose I am at a
exactly so great well I think that's it
for today's Q&A session if you'd like to
learn more about robotics visit
udacity.com/google calm Chris thank you
very much for joining me today it's been
a pleasure thank you thank you